now we always hear that like when like
just the wrestlers grind it's very uh
taxing very and right now you guys
aren't doing House shows like uh other
other companies right right but you guys
are still traveling
um how hard is it to juggle being a mom
being a wife having all this other stuff
going on while also being on the road
while also you know you're the premier
Talent on the female it's a lot it's a
lot you know we get home on Thursdays
majority of the time and my daughter
who's five the first thing she does is
want to play with me and I'm like baby
girl please like let me just take a nap
I've been up since four and I had to get
on this flight right after I probably
got maybe 30 minutes of sleep if
anything and um thankfully I have a
sport I mean a sport a husband who
played in sports who understands like
the grind and the fact that I need a
break and I need to relax like I got
home this week he sent me out with a
massage and everything like that like he
does stuff like that because he he
understands how much it is as far as
taxing on your body and on your mental
and just a fan base and if they don't
like you or whatever so
and the fact that I have a spouse who's
not in wrestling helps a lot because
only if I want to get away from the fan
base or anything like that negative
attention I could just put my phone down
yeah that's all I have to do and he can
care less he's like you want to talk
about wrestling nope okay let's talk
about what do you want to talk about and
I appreciate that so it's a lot
um I couldn't imagine having more than
one child right now I want more children
but right now it's like uh hell no it's
no way I could do it but uh it's a lot
it's a lot